let's start with a really striking chart
produced by the government showing you
the vaccine push and how it's going and
what you can see here these bars
showing you how many people have been
vaccinated so proportions of different
age groups as you can see
over 80s getting vaccinated the green
bit shows you first doses and then you
can gradually see different age groups
getting vaccinated and look now you can
start to see those
darker blue bars going up that's second
doses so proportion of people who have
been
had two jabs is going up and up and up
through every different age group and
that's kind of where we are at the
moment
uh good news in that you can see those
bars have gone very high higher than
many other countries
uh around the world but the health
secretary says he still wants to get
them up closer
to a hundred percent that's important
because of course this new variant the
indian variant is spreading around
the uk you get a sense of that when you
compare it to what's happened with
growth
of other variants so for instance this
shows you the brazilian variant pretty
much flat over the course
of the last few months then you've got
the south african very lots of talk
about that
but just have a look at the growth of
the indian variant incredibly sharp
uh increase in recent weeks up to just
under 3000 cases 2967 cases in total
at the moment and there are different
parts of the country that are affected
you probably remember
bolton being one of the hot spots let's
just zoom in there
um but the thing that we've noticed
going back to those vaccinations
is that it does seem to be a vaccine
effect so look at what's happening to
cases
for those who are under 60 people who
are less likely to be vaccinated
going up very sharply indeed but now
compare them to those
who are over 60 and they are really
quite low there's a gap that's opened up
and that gap actually seems to be
widening although overseas is going up a
little bit and if you look around
different parts of the country where the
health secretary says
they are doing surge testing new places
new names we've heard about for instance
burnley
the good news is we're not seeing as big
increases so
again under 60s not up quite as much
over 60s uh even less so that's
encouraging it's a similar story to in
many places like hounsley barely any
increase in there
at all even though there is surge
testing as well we'll monitor that over
the course of the next few weeks
but the key thing to bear in mind is
when you look across the country as a
whole
look case levels let's just tell you
showing you total daily case levels
are incredibly low at the moment until
that starts to rise we can be relatively
assured
that things are looking just about okay
right now